量子情報と量子計算の理解へようこそ。私はJohn Wattressで、IBMの教育担当テクニカルディレクターだ。
IBM Quantum。これはシリーズの第16回、最終レッスンで、テーマはフォールトトレラント量子
計算だ。前の3つのレッスンを通じて、量子誤り訂正符号のいくつかの例を見てきた。これらは量子エラーを検出し、
エラーが多すぎない限り訂正することができる。しかし、量子計算に誤り訂正を使いたい場合、まだ多くの
課題がある。その中には、量子gate、測定、状態
準備自体が不完全になりうるという現実も含まれる。例えば、量子誤り訂正符号を使って符号化された1つ
以上のqubitに誤り訂正を行う場合、それ自体が正しく動作しない可能性があるgateと測定を使って行わなければならない。
つまり、エラーの検出や訂正に失敗するだけでなく、新たなエラーを
導入してしまう可能性もある。さらに、完璧ではないgateを使って実際に行いたい計算を実行する必要もある。
計算を行うために量子情報をデコードして、それが終わったら
再エンコードするなんてリスクは絶対に冒せない。量子誤り訂正符号による保護がない状態でエラーが発生するかもしれないからだ。
つまり、量子誤り訂正符号の保護を一切外すことなく、論理qubit上で直接量子gateを実行する方法を
考え出さなければならない。これは大変な課題だが、ノイズのレベルが
ある閾値を下回る限り、ノイズの多いハードウェアを使って任意の大規模な量子計算を確実に実行することが実際に可能だと知られている。少なくとも
理論的には。この非常に重要な事実についてはレッスンの後半で議論する。ここでレッスンの
概要を簡単に紹介しよう。まずフォールトトレラント量子計算の基本モデルから始め、ノイズモデルの簡単な議論
と、量子circuitをフォールトトレラントに実装するための一般的な方法論も取り上げる。
次に、フォールトトレラント量子circuitにおけるエラー伝播の問題と、それを
制御する方法に移る。特に、エラー伝播を制御するためのとてもシンプルな方法を提供するtransversal gate実装について議論する。
ただし、この方法だけを使うことを妨げる根本的な制限もある。
また、いわゆるmagic stateを用いた別の方法論についても話す。これはエラー伝播を制御するための別の道を提供するものだ。
フォールトトレラント量子circuitでエラー伝播を制御する方法として、これが唯一の既知の方法というわけではない。最後に
レッスンは、少し前に言及した閾値定理のかなりハイレベルな議論で締めくくられる。
この定理は、すべてのコンポーネントのエラー率がある有限の閾値を下回る限り、任意の大規模な量子circuitを確実に実装できると述べている。
一般的に、この閾値は
使用する誤り訂正符号と、量子gateおよび測定のフォールトトレラント実装のための具体的な選択に依存するが、
実装するcircuitのサイズには依存しない。これは、大規模な
量子計算がいつか現実になると信じる十分な理由を与えてくれる。まず、フォールトトレラント量子
計算の基本モデルについて議論するところから始めよう。これは自然と量子circuitと量子誤り訂正符号に基づいている。この議論のために、
実装したい量子circuitがあると想像しよう。ここに示されているものがそれだ。これは
EBITの準備を含むテレポーテーションcircuitだ。しかし、この議論では具体的な内容はあまり重要ではない。これが
状態準備、ユニタリ
操作、測定を含む、もっと大きな別の量子circuitだとも想像できる。もちろんこのcircuitは理想を表しており、実際の
実装は完璧ではない。当然の疑問として、何がうまくいかない可能性があるのか
ということだ。うまくいかない可能性はかなり多い。例えば、状態初期化は一般的に
完璧ではない。もちろん、ユニタリgateも完璧ではないし、測定も
同様だ。さらに、qubit自体がノイズに影響されやすく、デコヒーレンスも含まれる。計算の
あらゆる時点で、これらのqubitに何も行われていなく単に量子情報を保存しているだけのときでさえそうだ。言い換えれば、ほとんど
すべてがうまくいかない可能性がある。ただし、1つ例外がある。少なくともそれが典型的な仮定で、
それは関与する古典的な計算は、おそらく欠陥がないだろうということだ。実質的にあらゆる目的において
古典的な計算は基本的に完璧だからだ。例えば、surface codeエラーの
訂正を計算するために古典的なマッチングアルゴリズムを実行する場合、この古典的な計算が欠陥を持つかもしれないとは心配しなくてよい。しかし、直接
量子情報に関わるものは欠陥を持つ可能性がある。もちろん、様々なことが起こる確率を関連付けるための正確なモデルが必要だ。
望むなら、現実で実際に起こることをできるだけ反映した複雑なモデルを作ることもできる。
しかし、モデルが複雑すぎると、扱いにくくなったり、興味深いことを言うのが困難または不可能になったりする可能性がある。
よく考慮されるノイズモデルの非常にシンプルな例の1つが
独立確率的ノイズモデルだ。このモデルでは、異なるコンポーネントに異なる時点で影響するエラーやフォールト、
言い換えればcircuitの異なる位置は独立している。
例えば、すべてのgateがある確率で失敗すると言えるし、ビット反転や位相反転は保存されたqubitに異なる
確率で単位時間あたりに発生するとも言える。しかし、仮定は異なる
エラー間に相関はないというものだ。このモデルに異議を唱えるかもしれない。おそらくエラー間にはある程度の相関があるからだ。
例えば、すべてのqubitを一度に消去してしまう壊滅的なエラーが発生する小さな確率があるかもしれない。
あるいはより可能性が高いのは、局所的だが複数のコンポーネントに影響するエラーが存在しうるということだ。
誰もそれを否定しない。しかし、それにもかかわらず、このモデルはシンプルなベースラインを表しており、
本質的には自然は予測不可能だが悪意はなく、量子計算を意図的に
台無しにしようとはしていないというアイデアを表している。より現実的だと言えるノイズモデルも他にある。そして
どのモデルを選んでも、もしそのモデルが間違った方向に導き、使用している
システムのエラーについて新しいことを学んだなら、自然に別のエラーモデルを策定して検討できる。次に、
量子circuitをフォールトトレラントに実装するための基本的な戦略を見ていこう。では、与えられた
論理量子circuit、つまり実行したい理想的な量子circuitを考えよう。例えば、先ほどと同じcircuitを考えることができる。
少し伸ばして示されているのは、フォールトトレラントな実装のために少しスペースが必要になるからだ。まず
状態準備、ユニタリgate、測定は、単一のgateとして直接実行されるわけではなく、
単一qubitの測定や状態準備としてでもなく、いわゆるガジェットによって実行される。ガジェットは
複数のqubitと複数の操作を含む場合がある。この図では、
これらの要素を紫色のボックスで囲んで示した。この紫色のボックスは、実装しようとする状態準備やgateのラベルが付いた小さなcircuitや演算のようなものだと考えていい。
次に、誤り訂正符号を使ってqubitを保護する必要がある。論理qubit自体がこれらのガジェットをつなぐのではなく、ガジェットはその論理qubitをエンコードする
物理qubitに作用する。そして、ここで強調する価値があるのは、我々が気にしている論理qubitが
決して露出しないという点だ。つまり、これらの論理qubitは使用する
量子誤り訂正符号によって保護された状態でその全生涯を過ごすことになる。そして最後に、エンコードされたqubitに対して誤り訂正を
計算の全体にわたって繰り返し実行する。基本的にチャンスがある度に行う。これを実行することは
非常に重要だ。直感的に言えば、誤りが発生するにつれて、qubitの状態にランダム性や不確実性が蓄積し始める。
そのランダム性やエントロピーを絶えず取り除く作業が必要だ。そしてそれは誤り訂正を通じて行われる。
qubitのランダム性やエントロピーを取り除き続ける必要がある。これが誤り訂正によって実現される。
つまり、これらの誤り訂正ステップは、論理qubitを冷たい状態に保つ小さな論理冷蔵庫やヒートポンプのようなものだと考えられる。
それによって計算が正しく動作できるようになる。
これらの選択がすべて完了したら、つまりすべてのガジェットの選択と符号の選択が完了し、特定のノイズモデルを仮定すると、
根本的な問いを立てることができる。それは、これは本当に役に立っているのか、ということだ。物事を改善しているのか、
それとも悪化させているのか。ノイズが多すぎる場合は、確かに悪化させている可能性がある。
誤りの確率が高すぎる場合、9Q Shor符号が物事を悪化させるのと同様に。
しかし、ノイズが一定の閾値を下回れば、この余分な作業がすべて報われる。そしてレッスンの終わりに向けて説明するように、
誤りをさらに削減する道が開ける。レッスンのこの部分では、フォールトトレラントな量子circuit内の誤り伝播について説明する。
先ほど説明した基本的な構造を持つcircuitだ。これは非常に重要な問題で、誤り伝播を制御できなければ、誤りが
誤り訂正の取り組みをすぐに圧倒してしまうからだ。しかし、誤りの伝播を制御できれば、符号ははるかに良い可能性を持つ。
つまり、十分な速度で誤りを訂正できるようになり、計算が
正しく機能するようになる。この議論の出発点は、2qubit gateやより一般的な複数qubit gateが
正常に機能している場合でも誤りを伝播させる可能性があるという認識だ。
一般的に、正しく機能していても誤りを伝播させる可能性がある。
例えば、C-not gateを考えてみよう。そして、C-not gateが実行される前に制御qubitでX誤りが発生したとする。
X誤りはちょうどX gateのように機能する。そして、
左のcircuitはC-not gateの後に両方のqubitでX誤りが発生する右のcircuitと等価であることがわかる。
これは誤りの伝播だ。左のX誤りの不運な位置が、それを右の2つのX誤りに変えてしまうからだ。
これを避けることはできない。C-not gateを使う限り、その直前に制御qubitでX誤りが発生する可能性が常にある。
そしてそれは2つのX誤りに伝播する。しかし後で見るように、このダメージを限定するための措置を取れば問題ない。
ところで、C-not gateの直前にターゲットqubitでZ誤りが発生した場合にも同じ現象が起きる。これについては
以前に議論したが、単純に掛け算を実行するか、
Qiskitを使ってこれらの等式を確認できる。重要な点は、この両方のケースで複数のqubitに相関誤りが生じるということだ。もちろん
C-not gate自体も故障する可能性があり、それも相関誤りを引き起こす可能性があることを
忘れてはならない。さらに懸念を加えると、後続の2qubit gateがこれらの誤りをさらに伝播させる可能性がある。
例えばX stabilizer generatorを測定するときに見られるような、このような3つのC-not gateがある場合、単一の誤りが
複数のqubitに急速に伝播する可能性がある。これが単一のコードブロック内で起きると、例えば
論理qubitをエンコードするqubitのグループ内で起きると、選んだ誤り訂正符号が
対処できなくなる。符号は低重みの誤りを訂正するように設計されており、このような高重みの誤りには対応できないからだ。
対応できない。符号は低重みの誤りを訂正するよう設計されており、このような高重みの誤りには対応できない。
だから、フォールトトレラントな量子circuitにおいてガジェットと誤り訂正ステップを考える際、これを常に念頭に置いておく必要がある。
フォールトトレラントな量子circuitにおける誤り伝播を軽減する最もシンプルな既知の方法は、gateを横断的に実装することだ。その意味については
すぐに説明する。フォールトトレラントなcircuit実装の図を視覚的な補助としてそのまま画面に表示しておこう。
ここでのアイデアは、一部の量子誤り訂正符号では、特定のgateを横断的に実装できるということだ。それは
各演算が各コードブロック内の単一のqubit位置にのみ作用する演算のテンソル積であるガジェットを使って実装することを意味する。
これはいくつかの例を通じて説明するのが最も分かりやすい。最初の、
そして間違いなく最も単純な例は、Pauli gateの横断的実装だ。
アイデアは、circuit内の各gateのガジェットを構築したいということだ。そしてすべての場合において、それらのガジェットは
テレポーテーションcircuitの末尾にあるX gateとZ gateのように、コードブロック上で動作する。もちろん、
デコードしてPauli gateを適用してから再エンコードすることはできない。それでは論理qubitが無防備な状態になり、再エンコードの結果として
コードブロック内で誤りが伝播する可能性があるからだ。
幸い、stabilizer符号を使う限りそうする必要はない。なぜならすべてのstabilizer符号では
論理qubitに直接Pauli演算を適用できるからだ。実際、エンコードに使われる物理qubitへのPauli gateのテンソル積でそれが実現できる。
物理qubitへのPauli gateのテンソル積でそれができる。
例えば、前のレッスンの終わりに登場した3x3 surface codeを考えると、この符号でエンコードされた論理qubitにX gateとZ gateを実装できる。
X gateとZ gateをidentity gateとともにテンソル積で結合することで、ここに示すパターンで実現できる。
これらのgateは各コードブロック内の単一のqubit位置にのみ作用するため、これらのgateの横断的実装と言える。
ここでは単一のqubit gateのみを使っているので、ある意味では自明だが、いずれにせよ、このようなガジェットは誤りを
コードブロック内で伝播させない。
ここでは単一qubit gateのみを使っているので、ある意味では自明だが、いずれにせよ、このようなガジェットは誤りを
伝播する。こうしたgadgetの中の個々のgateはどれも失敗する可能性があり、それでエラーが発生するが、
gadgetの直後に必ずエラー訂正を実行する。そしてエラー率が
十分に低ければ、エラー訂正コードがそのエラーを修正してくれる。
さっき言ったように、これはすべての安定化符号のpolygateについて常に可能だ。
ただし、目的のlogical poly演算を正しく実装するためには、gadget内のpolygateの適切なパターンを特定しなければならない。
別の例として、2つのcubic gateが関わる場合を見てみよう。今度はC not gateのtransversal実装を考えられる。
特に、すべてのCSSコードに対して、常にC not gateを実装できる。
2つのlogical cubit間のC not gateは、物理的なcubitの対応するペアにC not gateを実行するだけで実装できる。
これはtransversalである条件を満たしている。なぜなら、個々のC not gateはそれぞれのcode blockの中の
単一のcubitの位置にのみ作用するからだ。例えば、最初のC not gateは各code blockの最上位のcubitにのみ作用する。
2番目のC not gateは上から2番目のcubitにのみ作用する、といった具合だ。
この場合、エラーが伝播する可能性がある。なぜならC not gateはエラーを伝播させるからで、それを防ぐ
方法はない。しかし重要なのは、エラーの伝播が単一のcode block内で起きることはないということだ。例えば、
gadgetが実行される直前に上のcode blockの最上位のcubitにXエラーが発生した場合、最初のC not
gadget内でそのエラーが下のblockの最上位のcubitに伝播する。しかし結果として生じる2つのエラーは
別々のcode blockに存在する。だからgadgetの後に実行されるエラー訂正ステップは、それらのエラーを個別に修正できる。なぜならそれらの
エラーは各code block内の単一のcubitにしか影響しないからだ。
対照的に、エラーの伝播が同じcode block内で起きた場合は問題になりうる。なぜなら
エラーの伝播によって、コードが対処できないかもしれない高次のエラーに変わってしまうからだ。
この実装は非CSSコードには使えないが、CSSコードを使う限り、常にC not
gateをこの方法でtransversalに実装できる。もう一つ例を挙げると、すべての
Clifford gateはsteam codeに対してtransversalに実装できる。実際、任意のcolor codeに対しても同様で、これはcolor
codeの特に優れた点の一つだ。logical cubit上のHadamard gateは、個々の
物理的なcubitにそれぞれHadamard gateを実行することで実装でき、logical sgate は各cubitへのsgateではなく
各物理的なcubitへのs dagger gateで実装できる。つまり要点は、transversal gateの実装は本質的に
fault tolerantだということだ。なぜなら単一のcode block内でエラーを伝播させることがないからで、それがエラー訂正ステップに
これらのgadgetのgateによって発生または伝播したエラーを修正する機会を与える。それは素晴らしいことで、
fault tolerant gadgetを構築するための実にシンプルな方法だ。異なるgateのtransversal実装を可能にする異なるコードもあり、例えば
T gateなどがある。しかし残念ながら、非自明なコードに対してuniversalなgateのセットをtransversalに実装することは
不可能だ。これはeastern canel定理として知られる事実だ。より技術的な言葉では、
コードのdistanceが少なくとも2であれば、transversalに実装できるgateのセットは必然的にglobal phaseを除いて
離散的な演算のセットを生成する。したがってこのセットはuniversalではない。なぜなら universal gate
setは必然的に無限に多くの演算を生成するからだ。この定理の証明については説明しない。証明にはLie群とLie代数に関する
基本的な事実が使われるが、それはこのシリーズの前提知識ではない。しかし基本的なアイデアは、
無限族のtransversal演算はcode空間の中に留まることができない。なぜなら微小な
transversal演算の差分は低weightのpoly演算によってよく近似され、コードはそれをエラーとして検出するからだ。
gateをtransversalに実装できるのは非常に嬉しいことだ。しかし選んだコードに関係なく、この方法では
実装できないgateが必ず存在することがわかっている。だから代替のgadgetを探す必要がある。
eastern canal定理によれば、distance 2のquantum error correcting codeに対してさえ、universalなquantum gateのセットをtransversalに実装することは不可能だ。
だから少なくとも一部のgateについては、fault tolerantに実装する別の方法を見つける必要がある。
よく知られた方法の一つは、いわゆるmagic stateの利用だ。
この議論のために、SとT gateを思い出そう。これらは
画面に示されているように定義されたsingle cubic gateだ。まず、SはClifford演算であることに注目しよう。
それはClifford演算の定義から導かれる。また、poly行列をSで共役変換すると常に別のpoly行列の正負いずれかが得られることも確認できる。
そして第二に、TはClifford演算ではない。実際、TをHadamardとCotと組み合わせると、どちらも
Clifford演算だが、universalなquantum gateのセットが得られる。だからT gateを
Clifford演算と標準基底の測定だけで実装することはできない。しかし実は、Tate（T gate）を
Clifford演算と標準基底の測定で実装できる。ただし画面に示されている状態のコピーが
あれば、の話だ。それはTateをplus状態に適用したものだ。
この状態はmagic stateと呼ばれるが、それだけがmagic stateというわけではない。
magic stateという言葉は、このスキーム全体のバリエーションにおいてこの状態と似た役割を果たす異なる状態を指すのにも使われる。
例えば、ここに示されているcircuitがその役割を果たす。それほど難しくなく確認できる。
初期状態はトップのシステムを右に置いたものだ。C not gateを適用して簡略化すると、
ここに示されている状態が得られる。
下のcubitを測定してゼロが得られた場合（確率1/2で起こる）、
escapeは実行せず、出力はsに適用されたtになる。
1が測定された場合（もちろんこれも確率1/2で起こる）、escapeを適用すると正味の結果は
出力が再びsに適用されたtになる。ちなみにこれが唯一の方法ではない。同じタスクを達成する似たような
circuitが他にもあるが、これはその一つの方法だ。
これはquantum gate teleportationとして知られるものの、やや単純化された例だ。レッスン4で言及したもので、teleportationは
cubitを送るためではなく、gateを適用するために使われる。teleportationとの繋がりはここでは完全には明らかでないかもしれない。なぜなら
さっき言ったように、これは単純化されたバージョンで、tが対角行列だから使えるんだ。しかしもし興味があるなら
詳しく知りたい人は、量子gate teleportationというキーワードで調べてみるといい。
同様の方法でS gateを実装することもできる。この場合、必要なgateはC not gateとZ gateと測定だけだ。
これはS gateのtransversal実装がない場合に役立つ。なかなか興味深いが、これが実際に役立つかどうかは
必ずしも明らかではない。たとえばT gate実装の場合、
入力状態にT gateを適用しようとしている。ただしそのためには、plus状態にT gateを適用して
magic stateを得る必要があるように見える。S gate実装でも状況は似ている。重要なのは、
magic stateを得るためにまずplus状態を作ってそこにT gateを適用する必要は必ずしもないということだ。他にもこの状態を得る方法はある。そして
特に、実行中の計算でエラーの伝播を気にせずにこれを行える。なぜならmagic stateは
別途生成できるからだ。これにより、今から簡単に説明するT gateのfault tolerant実装が可能になる。
まず、ここに示した単純な2 qubit circuitをそのまま実行するわけではない。代わりにこのcircuitを
fault tolerant実装に使っているエラー訂正符号でエンコードされたqubitを使って実行する。つまり、
ユニタリgateと測定はfault tolerant gadgetで行われる。そのため
magic stateもエンコードされている必要がある。エンコードされたmagic stateさえ手に入れられれば、すべてfault tolerantになる。
ちなみにここでは、S gateのfall tolerant gadgetがすでにあると仮定している。
たとえばsteane符号を使っている場合は、S gateをtransversalに実装するだけでいい。それが使えない符号では、一つの選択肢として
このスキーム全体を使ってS gateをfault tolerantに実装し、その実装をここで使う方法がある。
ただしそれだけが選択肢ではない。いずれにせよ、実装の話に戻ると、残る重要な問いは、T gateのfault tolerant実装がまだない状態でどうやって
エンコードされたmagic stateを手に入れるかということだ。それを
単純にするわけにはいかない。鍵となるアイデアは、確率的なプロセスを使ってエンコードされたmagic stateを生成できるということだ。うまくいかなければ
それでも構わない。失敗した試みは捨ててやり直せばいい。
magic stateの生成は別途行われるため、実際に実行しようとしている計算を乱すことはない。
典型的な方法はmagic state distillationと呼ばれるプロセスだ。仕組みはこうだ。
distillerと呼ばれるcircuitがある。このdistillerにノイズの多いmagic stateの集まりを入力し、
出力のうち一つを残して他をすべて測定する。測定結果がすべてゼロという条件を満たせば、
出力はよりノイズの少ないmagic stateになる。これをさらに別のdistillerへの入力qubitの一つとして使える。
このプロセスを繰り返し、測定結果のどれかがゼロ以外で失敗したらやり直す。あるいは使いたい計算にT gateを安全に実装できるほど品質の高いmagic stateが得られるまで続ける。
計算で必要なT gateの実装に安全に使える十分な品質のmagic stateが得られるまで続けるわけだ。
distillerの構築方法にはいくつかの既知の方法があるが、どれも基本的に同じ仕組みで動いている。つまりstabilizer符号のデコーダーで、
エンコードcircuitの逆演算だ。これは都合がいい。distillerがClifford
演算になれるからだ。最後に、このdistillationプロセスは実際には論理qubitレベルで行われる。つまり現実には、
distillerと測定のためのgadgetをすべて使って行われる。このプロセスにも
出発点が必要だ。ただしノイズ率が高すぎなければ、ノイズはあるが十分な品質の
magic stateを作って始めることができる。たとえば、plus状態のqubitに実際のノイズのあるT gateを適用し、
そのqubitをエンコードすることで始められる。非常に高レベルな説明だったが、仕組みの大まかなイメージは伝わったと思う。
gateをtransversalに実装するよりずっと複雑だが、それでもtransversal gate実装だけではできない、量子gateの普遍的なセットをfault tolerantに実装する方法を提供してくれる。
gateをtransversalに実装するだけでは実現できないものだ。magic stateを使ってgateをfault tolerantに実装する際のオーバーヘッドは非常に高いと言われることがある。
作業の大部分がmagic stateのdistillationに費やされ、実際の計算の実行はおまけのようなものになるという話だ。
しかし実際にはそれほど明確ではなく、この方法が
実は実用的だと明らかにした詳細な分析もある。gateをfault tolerantに実装するための既知のスキームは他にもいくつかある。code deformationやcode switchingは
そうしたスキームに関連した名前で、新しい方法が開発・改良され続けているが、このレッスンではそれらの
方法については説明しない。量子circuitのfault tolerant実装に関するもう一つの重要な問題があり、
それはエラー訂正ステップそのものに関係している。つまりgateの実装の話ではなく、
実際のエラー訂正の話だ。問題は、
レッスン14で最初に見た、位相推定に基づいてstabilizer generatorを測定するシンプルなcircuitについて考えると、それらが
それ自体はfault tolerantではないことがわかる。なぜなら単一の符号ブロック内でエラーが伝播する可能性があるからだ。
これは、量子情報に関わるものはすべてエラーの影響を受けるという考えに立ち返るものだ。エラーを訂正するためのcircuit自体も例外ではない。
これはかなり問題があるように思えるが、実はこの問題には複数の既知の解決策がある。
いくつか紹介するが、詳しくは説明しない。ところで、fault tolerant量子コンピューティングは
複雑で気にすべき詳細がたくさんあるという印象を受けているなら、それは当然だし事実だ。動いている部品がたくさんある。
このレッスンの目的はすべての詳細を説明することではなく、全体の仕組みについての基本的な入門を提供することだ。
仕組みの基本的な入門だ。fault tolerant量子エラー訂正の一つの方法はShor error correctionと呼ばれ、Peter
Shorがこの方法を最初に提案したことにちなんで名付けられている。アイデアは、いわゆるcat stateを使って各シンドローム測定を行うことだ。
3 qubitの場合はGHZ stateと同じものだが、測定しようとするstabilizer generatorの重みに合わせて任意の数のqubitに一般化できる。
特に、ここに示したcircuitはstabilizer generatorの測定に使える。そして
この方法は符号ブロック内でエラーを伝播させないことが示せる。
cat state自体を生成する必要がある。エラーや場合によっては欠陥のあるgateがある状況でも確実に動作させるために、この方法では実際に
このようなcircuitを繰り返し実行し、プロセス中にどこでエラーが発生したかを推論する必要がある。
代替方法はSteane error correctionと呼ばれ、Andrew Steineによって最初に提案された。
この方法は異なる仕組みで動作し、CSS符号にのみ対応している。この方法では、実行しようとしているcircuit内のエンコードされた量子状態に対してシンドローム測定を行うのではなく、
意図的にエラーをworkspaceシステムに伝播させ、
そのシステムを測定して古典的にエラーを検出する。ここに示した図は、X errorについてこれを行う方法を示している。この場合workspace
qubitは最初にプラス状態のエンコードに設定される。つまりこれは基本的に
C NOTゲートのトランスバーサル実装で、ターゲットがプラス状態にあるため何もしないはずだ。しかし、
上側のqubitにXエラーがあった場合、それが下のシステムに伝播して検出される。Zエラーを検出する同様の方法もある
が、ここでは示していない。Manny Canilが最初に提案したカニルエラー訂正という関連手法もある
が、それはトランスバーサルC NOTではなくテレポーテーションに基づいており、任意のスタビライザー
符号に対して機能し、CSS符号だけに限らない。
このレッスンで最後に説明するのは、閾値定理として知られる非常に重要な定理だ。やや非形式的な
定理の記述はこうだ。nをいくら大きくしてもよいとして、nのgateを持つ任意のquantum circuitがある場合、
ノイズのレベルが
nに依存しないある閾値以下であれば、ノイズのあるquantum circuitを使って高精度でそのcircuitを実装することが可能だ。しかも、これを行うのはそれほど
コストが高くない。必要なノイズのあるcircuitのサイズは、nにnの対数のある定数乗を掛けた
オーダーだ。定理をより形式的に述べるにはノイズモデルを特定する必要があるが、このレッスンではそこまでやらない。
例えば、以前述べた独立確率的ノイズモデル、すなわちエラーがcircuit内の各可能な位置で
この閾値より真に小さいある確率で独立して発生するモデルについて証明できる。しかし、
エラー間に相関がある、より一般的なノイズモデルについても証明できる。これは理論的な
結果であり、証明の典型的な方法は必ずしも実際に行うことに直接対応するわけではないが、それでも
実用的な意味で非常に重要な定理だ。その理由は、これが基本的に、ノイズのある構成要素を使って
量子計算を実行することに根本的な障壁はないということを示しているからだ。
これらの構成要素のエラー率がこの閾値以下である限り、任意の大きさの信頼性の高いquantum circuitを構築するのに使える。
別の言い方をすると、この定理が真でなければ、大規模な量子コンピューティングが
現実のものになるとは想像しにくい。この定理の形式的な証明には多くの技術的な詳細が伴うが、それを
伝えようとはしない。しかし、高いレベルで基本的なアイデアを説明しようとは思う。また、その基本的な
アイデアと実際に何が起こりうるかをゆるやかに結びつけようと思う。ではこれがわれわれのcircuitだとしよう。レッスン全体で
話し続けてきたのと同じcircuitだ。しかし、circuitはこれよりはるかに大きく複雑なものだと想像できる。この
circuitを実装したいが、構成要素はすべてノイズがある。独立確率的ノイズ
モデルを簡単のために使うとすると、各可能な位置でエラーが独立して発生する確率Pがある。
circuitがこの確率Pの逆数より相当大きければ、直接実装では
正しく動かないとほぼ確信できる。そこでこのレッスンでここまで説明したようにcircuitをフォールト
トレラントに実装する作業をすべて行い、先ほど提起した問いを自分に投げかける。それは、物事を
改善しているのか、それとも悪化させているのかということだ。構成要素それぞれのエラー確率を表す確率Pが大きすぎる場合、
これは役に立たない。ちょうど9Q Shor符号がエラー確率が約3と4分の3%を超えると役に立たないのと同様に。
特に、circuitは大きくなった。なので、エラーが発生しうる場所がずっと多くなる。
しかし、Pが十分に小さければ、これは役に立つ。実質的にやることは、実行している論理計算の
エラー確率を下げることだ。では、もう少し詳しく考えてみよう。
できるだけ簡単な設定で主なアイデアを見るために、エラー訂正に7 qubit スティアン符号を使うとしよう。
この符号は1コードブロックあたり最大1つのエラーを訂正できる。したがって、論理エラーが
元のcircuitで発生するには、フォールトトレラント実装において同じコードブロックに少なくとも2つのエラーが
落ちてこなければならない。
同じコードブロックに2つ以上のエラーが発生する方法がたくさんあることを念頭に置くと、元のcircuit内の各位置での論理エラーの確率は
高々C * P ^ 2であると主張できる。ここでCは符号と
使用するガジェットに依存する数だ。しかし重要なのは、元のcircuitのサイズには依存しないということだ。
したがって、PがCの逆数より小さい場合、それが閾値として取れる数だが、これは
エラーの減少に対応する。つまりcircuitをフォールトトレラントに実装する努力が実を結んでいる
ということだ。しかし、この新しいエラー率はまだcircuit全体が正しく動くには高すぎるかもしれない。だから
もっとやる必要がある。実際には、この時点で自然にやることは、より良い符号とより良いガジェットを選んでエラー
率を実装が機能しそうなところまで下げることだ。
理論的に言えば、これが可能だと主張する簡単な方法は連結することだ。つまり、
元のcircuitのフォールトトレラント実装を新しい論理circuitとして考える。そしてそれをフォールト
トレラントに実装する。そしてこれを必要なだけ何度も繰り返す。するとエラーが
非常に速く減少することがわかる。これが紙の上で閾値定理が典型的に証明される方法だ。
形式的に証明するのに必要な多くの技術的詳細を省いて、エラー率がどのように低下するかのごく大まかなアイデアを示そう。
元の構成要素のエラー確率Pから始める。circuitを
フォールトトレラントに実装すると、エラーはC * Pという係数だけ減少する。次にフォールトトレラントな
実装を論理circuitとして扱い、フォールトトレラントに実装すると、エラー率の同様の減少が得られる。しかし
元のcircuitの実効エラー率を考えると、それがさらに下がることがわかる。今では
エラー率PをC * P ^ 2に置き換えているからだ。それが第1レベルのフォールトトレラント
実装後の実効エラー率だからだ。具体的には、少し代数を行うと、エラーはCP
3乗 * Pまで下がることがわかる。もう一度やると、エラー率はCP ^ 7 * Pになる。そして
合計Kレベルにわたってこれを続けると、エラーがKについて二重指数関数的に縮小することがわかる。だから
エラー率を非常に小さくするためにこれをそれほど多く繰り返す必要はない。
一方、circuitは大きくなっているが、サイズはKについてただ指数関数的にしか増加しない。それぞれの
フォールトトレランスのレベルで、circuitのサイズは最大でも
私たちのgadget。そしてすべてをまとめ、連結レベル数の適切な選択が
行われると、閾値定理が得られる。しかしすでに示唆したように、これを形式化するには多くの詳細が必要だ。では、
現実においてこの閾値はどのくらいなのか？それはcodeとgadgetに依存する。
Steane codeとmagic state distillationを用いた場合、その値は極めて小さく、実際には達成困難だろう。
しかしsurface codeと最先端のgadgetを使えば、約1%と推定されている。これは
悪くない。そして新しいcodeや手法が発見されるにつれ、この値は上昇すると合理的に期待できる。それと同時に、
私たちが構築するコンポーネントのノイズレベルも低下していくだろう。
大規模な量子計算をfault tolerantに実装できる段階に達することは容易ではなく、一晩では実現しない。
しかしこの定理と、これまでに目撃してきた量子codeおよび量子ハードウェアの進歩が
私たちに必要な楽観主義を与えてくれる。大規模なfault tolerant量子コンピュータを構築するという究極の目標に向けて前進し続けるための。
これがレッスンの終わりであり、シリーズの終わりでもある。
このシリーズに価値を見出してもらえたなら、ぜひ同僚や友人に勧めることを検討してほしい。
また、IBM Quantum Learningで追加のコースやチュートリアルを確認し、Qiskit
YouTubeチャンネルをまだ登録していなければ購読してほしい。今後のコンテンツリリースを最新の状態で追えるように。視聴してくれて
ありがとう。